el proyecto de reforma tributaria en
Colombia fue presentado apenas un día
después desde la posesión de Gustavo
Petro como nuevo mandatario a principios
de agosto pasado casi tres meses después
se fue aprobado aunque con
modificaciones respecto de la propuesta
original Ahora solo está pendiente la
conciliación es de las dos cámaras y la
firma presidencial el oficialismo Espera
que el recaudo de 20 billones de pesos
unos 4.000 millones de dólares
adicionales por año sirvan para
financiar proyectos para las comunidades
vulnerables como alcantarillados y
educación además de impulsar esa Paz aún
esperada tras el acuerdo con la
extirilla de las Farc en 2016 sin
embargo la oposición ve con preocupación
los nuevos impuestos a sectores
productivos como el minero energético
así como el IVA en algunos productos de
la canasta familiar vamos entonces a
pasar al momento de esta entrevista y
para ello me acompaña a mi compañera
Daniela Blandón y nuestro invitado es
Luis Fernando Mejía economista director
ejecutivo de fe desarrollo Muchas
gracias solucionando por estar con
nosotros y como esta reforma puede
afectar el peso colombiano que ya es uno
de los más devaluados en la región
Hola qué tal gracias por la invitación
un saludo muy especial Pues mira lo
primero es que esta reforma tiene
elementos bastante positivos
especialmente en lo que tiene que ver
por ejemplo con aumentar la tributación
de las personas de más altos ingresos
por ejemplo también se incluyen esta
reforma un impuesto al patrimonio para
aquellos que tienen patrimonios por
encima de alrededor de los 600 mil
dólares Así que tiene elementos bastante
positivos destacables preocupaciones de
fondo que tenemos todavía con esta
reforma el primero el aumento tan
importante en la tributación para el
sector minero energético que en Colombia
básicamente son dos productos que hacen
parte esencial de esta canasta el
petróleo y el carbón que en la reforma
pues se le ha aumentado sustancialmente
justamente esa carga tributaria y por
otro lado el aumento al impuesto a los
dividendos que también podría generar
algo digamos desde incentivos a la
inversión en el país Así que es una
reforma que tiene elementos positivos
otros no tantos y adelante va a depender
fundamentalmente el comportamiento del
dólar de que diga el gobierno sobre cuál
va a ser la destinación específica de
estos recaudos adicional si estos 4.000
millones de dólares se gastan
completamente no va a mejorar la
posición del gobierno nacional la
posición fiscal y Por ende podría haber
presiones adicionales al alza en el
dólar si por el contrario el gobierno
Dice que una parte importante del
recaudo se va a destinar a reducir el
déficit fiscal apagar la deuda esto
Podría tener efectos positivos en
materia justamente de la tasa de cambio
Luis Fernando que gusto saludarlo le
pregunto por uno de los unos de los
artículos más polémicos de esta
propuesta fue precisamente el IVA
algunos productos de la canasta familiar
en lo que el gobierno ha dicho que es un
impuesto más que para recaudo adicional
por un tema de salud para quitarle
presión a los al sistema de salud que
estamos hablando de los celo a los
alimentos Ultra procesados Cómo ve
ustedes impuesto y hay ejemplos en otros
países de la región en los que o países
del mundo en los que haya funcionado un
impuesto de esta categoría
pues mire la verdad es que nosotros
estamos Completamente de acuerdo con
esta propuesta que ha introducido el
gobierno nacional y realmente es una
señal de política pública en salud en
donde es un sobre impuesto una sobre
tasa Si se quiere a el consumo de
ciertos alimentos ultraprocesados y
bebidas con exceso de azúcar que
pretenden desestimular justamente el
consumo de este tipo de alimentos o
bebidas por sus consecuencias negativas
en materia de salud Colombia no es el
primer país que adopta un impuesto este
tipo los impuestos saludables ya tiene
una historia bastante amplia no
solamente en países de Europa sino
también Incluso en países de la región
como México y Las evaluaciones que se
han hecho técnicas o de los impactos
parecen sugerir que en efecto hay un
cambio en el comportamiento de las
personas es fundamental que esto se
acompañe por supuesto con una estrategia
grande comunicación para que la gente
entienda Por qué se le está poniendo un
impuesto adicional a este tipo de
alimentos y bebidas Así que nos parece
razonable un elemento negativo de que
afecta especialmente a los hogares más
pobres quienes destinan una proporción
mayor de su ingreso justamente la compra
este tipo de alimentos o bebidas pero
pensando más bien en el largo plazo en
los efectos positivos en salud
consideramos que incluso a pesar de esa
regresividad es una medida que tiene
todo el sentido es una buena señal desde
el punto de vista política pública Luis
Fernando qué preocupaciones debería
tener la gente pues la gente del común
sobre esta reforma tributaria porque
sabemos que las empresas terminaron Pues
con un impuestos más altos sobre todo el
sector minero energético pero las
personas del común qué preocupaciones
deben tener Luis Fernando
Pues a ver lo que pasa es que estamos en
un año que llega a 2023 muy pronto que
va a ser bastante complicado por varios
elementos el ambiente internacional que
no es favorable los vientos de recesión
en varios países incluyendo Alemania el
Reino Unido eventualmente Estados Unidos
y en ese contexto además en donde
Colombia ha tenido un proceso de
inflación bastante alta en donde llegan
superamos el 12% anual con el último
dato publicado para el mes de octubre
Pues indudablemente el próximo año va a
ser un año complicado en materia
económica si a eso se le suman los
efectos eventuales de estas reforma
especialmente en los incentivos a la
inversión y al crecimiento económico
podríamos tener el próximo año
eventualmente un deterioro de la
generación de empleo es decir un aumento
en la tasa de desempleo que podría
afectar por supuesto a los hogares
especialmente a los más pobres y
vulnerables Así que va a ser un año
difícil no solamente por la reforma
tributaria sino especialmente por el
ambiente internacional
Así que hay que apretarse el cinturón
tener mucho cuidado con los gastos que
se hagan las compras porque va a ser de
nuevo ratificó un año bastante difícil
en materia económica